ciao ragazzi il bentornato in una
puntata di cucina buttata oggi faremo
uno dei miei piatti preferiti di con
thereau piccolo un piatto che si trova
nel balcone surgelati i sofficini ma
cercheremo di farli in casa
gianmarco è riuscito a trovare un video
di questi ragazzi che si chiamano 55 ho
visto il 55 vi lasciamo in qua sotto
nel quale effettivamente c'erano dei
sofficini pazzeschi distinguono tra una
cottura al forno è una cottura fretta il
link ve lo lascio qua sotto i sofficini
si trigono non metterò mai all'interno
di quel forno dei sofficini per creare
una grande enorme eresia
oggi si fallisce però di averlo rosa
stati cioè pericoloso aver ma
ultimamente ci sta venendo tutto quanto
troppo bene vedo che succede
partiamo subito con gli ingredienti per
fare l'impasto avremmo bisogno di 400
grammi di farina 800 1000 litri di latte
una noce di burro in che senso una noce
di burro del burro che rende 41 quindi
una noce di cervello e del sale quanto
basta
la cosa è il quanto basta un po strana
perché loro buttano un sacco di sale
perché una preparazione è stata avanzata
ma è tale per il ripieno abbiamo bisogno
di polpa di pomodoro e mozzarella
inoltre con diremo con un pochino di
specie la polpa di pomodoro vedremo un
pochino che cosa abbiamo in dispensa e
infine per l'impanatura 2 of what's up l
compie e del pangrattato occhi sul
procedimento 800.000 litri di latte
riversiamo all'interno di una pentola
aggiungiamo la noce di burro il sale qb
magari rimane un po di sale detto la
tazzina di caffè non mi avete vomitano
questa fiamma spenta sì se cioè si fa
col potere dell'immaginazione
adesso cosa dobbiamo fare far andare sul
fuoco il latte finché non andrà a
bollire quando bollirà aggiungeremo una
farina piano di fare altro pivot
tagliare a cubetti la mozzarella la
mozzarella taglieremo nel momento in cui
si raffredderà l'impasto perché comunque
non puoi stenderlo
quando no è che fase le rimane da dentro
e fa un problema enorme ma il mattino a
prenderti una di anna una ghianda di
tranquillante la pentola si sta
arrabbiando sentirà beni che ci siamo no
no sì perché si è comprato non lo so non
lo so sta uscendo arrabbiando impazzendo
sta uscendo stava andando a picchiarci
queste ragazzine qualcosa non torna
primo in chiave di legno a ben altra
cosa perché lo mangerei arrivo tu
mangeresti stoke e up
non so perché tu abbia ancora le pulci
al polso del presenza stuzzicando la 30
ma da preparare qui intanto il ripieno
in polpa di pomodoro sale basilico o un
problema non rivelatori nel sociale
brillato ma che schifo
il mio freezer sia ghiacciato non so
come e non si aprono più riassetti
datamatic è andato mi spieghi perché tu
tieni fasi virtuale fritte o mio dio
non si toglie stanno cercando non ve lo
consiglio lascialo o mamma mia lasciano
questo tipo il salto e vola a avere
gente che ti tocca la roba mentre la
prima linea
fatemi solamente sapere che cosa ne
pensate terribile è il fatto che cucini
comunque la cucina è un gioco di squadra
sono troppo individualista egocentrico
centrico individualista anarchico ma che
ora basta a me da un sacco di
insoddisfazione dall'agguato male già
borsarella e allegro card che sa niente
non è la mozzarella campana doc di
bufala che è l'unica che io accetto
veramente nella mia tavola ma per queste
preparata pasca della mia tattica ma per
queste preparazioni filanti e cose così
in qeusta perfetta poniamo la mozzarella
non abbiate paura di abbondare con la
mozzarella perché tanto poi
sciogliendosi andrà ad unirsi comunque
al sugo zana rischia di essere troppo
troppo poco filante e troppo liquido
tricot r770 l'urlo di quadra
non lo so ragazzi brocci in tour e colla
peggio ancora se non avessi le mani
capaci di affondare nelle fiamme
io a quest'ora starebbe morendo bello
già mi pare passarlo voglio vedere se tu
soffri è caldo si sopportabile guardate
come viene alla fine prova a fare come
se stessi a pallavolo
tagliamo farina spendiamoli signor
mattarella andiamo a stenderlo questo è
uno dei mattarelli più scomodi che siano
mai stati creati quello di legno oltre a
vita perché questo è il minimo nudo chi
l'ha creato non ha pensato alla
possibilità di fare questo movimento che
ti lascia tutte le righe che l'iraq
mistica io sono stanco di rischiare di
farmi male per gli sportelli anarchia in
cucinati è chiuso lo sportello sai
comodo come può che cosa al mondo
il sole cui versiamo lo sportello
ora io uso questa tazza bello questo qui
è altissima da questo ne escono 20 dei
soffitti dovessi vendere gli uffici mi
pare che le confezioni in aula hai
segnato un mattarello accanato un
mattarello può far boccino d'oro con
l'impasto si è stato
enrico non deve andare ma identico
sembrano quelli della banca per ora
sembra anche un po yoda in realtà a
paper crei gel marco crisi e da molte
palazzine matrimonio preacher dopo il
matrimonio del rivolte erano fichissimo
citrus no arrows the week debouchè la
parte non salire jazz mondiale
io teoricamente avere finito ha perso
pellicola caso in cui i rosa ma appunto
con la zardo e jackson che sopravvive
mettiamo due ok ma l'acqua come mai
l'acqua prendi col pennello vivacqua
qualcosa a ri ammorbidire gli crei le
premesse per la chiusura sta diventando
bravo è vero non c'è più quel brivido in
completo disastro non succede mai
bellissima io direi di provare a farne
tutti finché almeno non finisce il
condimento e ci vediamo quando abbiamo
finito questo procedimento
apriamo un uomo attento locali nel luogo
con delicatezza ciò il terrore a
distruggerlo finiamo di impararli e poi
passiamo alla frittura stubbs stop a
mazzate friedli serio sì ma queste sono
cose che vanno abbastanza immerse
nell'olio
però vorrei anche far notare come
veramente sia facile fare soffice in
casa non fai assolutamente delirio ma
voglia di andarmene
credo che non ho avuto dai secoli riso
sofficini assurdamente simili creste
averli presi dalla confezione per 20
quando ce n'è uno che ha quasi rotta
inquietante interezza con elisa guarda
come guardato ferito gravissimo sta
catalizzando tutto e per il tuo bene da
ce la puoi fare sala soffrendo
prepariamo a impiantare tutto quanto mai
mai
teniamo ad aggiungere rotta questa mamma
non me lo deve essere affatto lente un
bel lavoro e tu intanto per servire che
faccio un attimo gli onori di casa
allora ragazzi come sempre vi ricordo
che se avete buon cuore lasciateci un
pollice in su per il iscrivete a questo
canale attiva della campanella delle
notifiche fateci sapere che cosa
vorreste vedere nei prossimi episodi
cucina buttata se siete invece delle
persone cattive
fate sempre lo stesso andiamo ad
assaggiarlo subito io però non voglio il
tuo autorizzato
marco no super croccanti invece un bosco
di una purezza ma io faccio la prova
anni 90 30 trucco e senza inganno sono
buonissimi compatti bollenti nera minima
che in regione che c'è questo è mamma
mia
la prova del sorriso faccio vedere
ambiente non gli piace proprio sori da
questi ma mia
questo paragone allora bucio ma c'è
pochissimo 999 ragazze sempre piaciuta
ricetta volete rifarla e sporcare tutto
quello che avete in casa pagatemi su
instagram oscillanti e niente noi ci
vediamo martedì prossimo alle 12 con un
nuovo prog settimanale bomba sotto
impressionati
il pezzo di basilico